wie schön dass sie dabei sind sag ich
immer aber diesmal stimmt so toll meine
damen und herren dass sie tatsächlich
heute vor der glotze sitzen am letzten
freitag mit offenen kneipen für lange
zeit
ab montag ist schon wieder lockdown
unter anderem für die arme
gastronomiebranche für die kommen jetzt
noch mal ein paar richtig harte wochen
aber auch für den ganzen kultur und
veranstaltungsbereich wahnsinn wahnsinn
was da im ohnehin trostlosen november
alles auf eis gelegt wird
beispiele schwimmbäder spaß binder
seinen themen sie können das dann im
einzelnen natürlich alles noch einmal
nachlesen veranstaltungen die der
unterhaltung dienen werden untersagt
veranstaltungen die der unterhaltung
dienen werden untersagt ja das war die
heute show jetzt kommt aspekte schöner
abschluss bis nächste woche
nein spaß nur spaß wenn du spaß
wir sind ja gar keine unterhaltung wir
sind ja kabarett über gut so was kommt
da auf uns zu ab kommenden montag mein
richtiger lockdown käme mit
ausgangssperre
was kriegen wir genau einen
wellenbrecher shutter und lockt
downlight wellenbrecher lockdown der
fast locker und ein kurzer kompletter
lockdown ein weicher lockdown ein
längerer teil knock down irgend ein
längeres weiches teil keine ahnung
lockdown leid danach kommt
wahrscheinlich lockdown zero da darf man
sich mit 0 anderen leuten treffen und
natürlich lockdown grünkohl mango wenn
wirklich alles nur noch zum kotzen ist
ganze branchen werden in den vorzeitigen
winterschlaf geschickt
bin mal gespannt wer danach noch
aufwacht gastronomen die viel geld in
funktionierende hygiene konzepte
investiert haben müssen jetzt dafür dass
der staat den sommer eben nicht genutzt
hat um gesundheits und ordnungsämter
rechtzeitig aufzurüsten und für die
ignoranz einer handvoll volkes ich trage
einen mund nasen bedeckung die die
forderung erhöht ich habe niemals geld
es ist das geld reicht mir nächste stufe
ist dann zu einem chor ohne gültige höhe
richtig guten herrlich kontakt
reduzierung ist das gebot der stunde
damit schulen und einzelhandel auf
bleiben macht der ganze freizeitbereich
jetzt mal dicht ob wir damit das
exponentielle wachstum stoppen weiß
keiner
ehrlich gesagt drei viertel der
infektionen sind gar nicht mehr zurück
zu verfolgen
da geht es vielleicht nicht ohne
radikalere maßnahmen allerdings muss man
dann mindestens vorher darüber streiten
idealerweise in parlamenten denn wie hat
eine weise opfer merken gestern so
treffend bemerkt wie kritische debatte
ist schlecht ich dem demokratie im
gegenteil sie stärksten war wo kritische
debatte voll stark leider gab es die
debatte aber erst nachdem frau merkel
mit der üblichen hinterzimmer runde
längst alles ausgekugelt hatte wenn das
parlament so massive grundrechts
einschnitte nur noch posthum
kommentieren darf wozu haben wir das
dann ernst gemeinte frage ich möchte
heute auch mal ausdrücklich an jeden und
jede einzelne appellieren und da meine
ich dich dich dich dadurch nicht wisst
ihr noch was ihr vor corona manchmal in
der hütte hier gemacht habt wisst ihr
das noch gesetze ließ das habt ihr
debattiert und beschlossen ihr könnt das
auch wenn diese frau ich das nicht mehr
zutraute die hier denken nur sie werden
das volk aber ihr seid dass
volksvertreter also traurig abgeordneter
mach es zu deinem gesetz
ich glaube an euch der bundestag muss
endlich den rahmen für all die maßnahmen
beschließen das infektionsschutzgesetz
ist noch auf lokale masernausbrüche
zugeschnitten
kein wunder dass corona verordnung
reihenweise von deutschen gerichten
kassiert werden
schon über 60 mal da drängt die zeit
sagt auch der bundestagspräsident
seine partei die cdu hat weniger eilig
das werden wir auch jetzt in ruhe
angehen und werden uns überlegen wie wir
es bei der nächsten pandemie dann auch
so machen können dass die bedenken des
bundestags präsidentin dann auch
entsprechend berücksichtigt werden hat
er gesagt bei der nächsten pandemie gibt
es da schon termin macht mal genauso
weiter freunde
was wir brauchen ist eine neue corona
strategie vielmehr schnelltests eine
bessere corona app vielleicht sogar mit
vorübergehend weniger strengen
datenschutz ist mal was neues handeln
wir uns doch nur von einem lok down zum
nächsten
wir sind schlicht zu langsam für dieses
virus im moment ist das wie im rennen
zwischen wahnsinnig usain bolt und peter
altmaier kann man nicht gewinnen
so leidet also einmal mehr die
gastronomie aber wissen sie eigentlich
wen es corona bedingt noch viel härter
erwischt hat friedrich merz wirklich der
mann stand so kurz vor der kanzlerschaft
und dann sagen die schweine seinen cdu
krönungs parteitag einfach ab seit
gestern abend ist der letzte teil der
kampagne märz verhindern in berlin
angelaufen cool kampagne friedrich merz
verhindern wo kann man da unterschreiben
es ist schon bezeichnend wenn jemand
glaubt seine weltweite pandemie dreht
sich letztlich nur um ihn irgendwie wer
steckt dahinter der tollen kampagne ich
merke dass seit einigen wochen es gibt
teile des partei establishments ist in
teil es ist nicht das sind nicht alle
aber beachtliche teile die verhindern
wollen dass ich parteivorsitzender werde
natürlich das verdammte establishment
wird ihnen fertig machen was ist mit
diesem land los jetzt kämpfen wir schon
millionäre gegen das establishment der
sarah drew die dusche
die cdu hat ihren parteitag also
hauptsächlich verschoben um ihn zu
verhindern
das klingt vielleicht für den laien weit
hergeholt andererseits
[Musik]
deutschland 2020 die cdu sucht einen
neuen vorsitzenden und im selben jahr
tobt die korona pandemie hier stimmt
doch was nicht
ein recherche verbund aus russia today
prima kreis-anzeiger und attila hildmann
stiftung deckt auf die cdu hat das virus
im labor gezüchtet die aktion märz
verhindern beginnt als der
wissenschaftler armin l im januar eine
fledermaus infiziert und sieht der ubs
nach johann schickt von dort gelangt das
anti märz virus zum hotspot heinsberg
das café ist nur einen oster entfernt
von amina schied wahlkreis haaren und
norbert röttgens wohnort königswinter zu
fall
wohl kaum und welche rolle spielen die
notorischen system uhren vom zdf der
nackel senderschnitt ausgerechnet ralf
kabelka spitzname solchen ralle zum
cdu-parteitag sein auftrag ein feiges
treppchen attentat auf den kanzler
herzen und nächste woche
wer hat an merz flugzeug die
bremsschläuche durchgeschnitten
das und mehr völlig erfundene fakten bei
zdf history
[Musik]
präsentiert von friedrich merz die
wahrheit ist irgendwo da draußen ja
wollen wir hoffen dass wenigstens unsere
schulen noch eine weile weitermachen
offen bleiben an manchen hotspots findet
ja längst wieder hybrider unterricht
statt
achten sie mal darauf so nennt man das
jetzt hybrider unterricht weil die
eltern beim wort homeschooling direkt
pickel kriegen
gleichzeitig fühlen sich die lehrkräfte
einmal mehr von der politik im stich
gelassen
deutschlands lehrer sollten einfach mal
danke für gar nichts ja genau
danke für gar nichts über acht monate
corona und wir sind kein millimeter
weiter ich krieg briefe von der
schulbehörde da steht drin alle 20
minuten lüften geile idee
es sei denn man kann die scheiß fenster
kann nicht aufmachen
das betrifft 100.000 klassenzimmer in
deutschland schon vor krone hat hier
gerochen wie im bottich apportieren
kommt bitte mama fenster auf ganz
ehrlich wir diskutieren über zu enge
schweine buchten aber wie erhalten wir
denn bitte unsere kinder wir erlauben
fenster pausen die schülerinnen und
schüler dürfen zwischendurch auf wunsch
zum geöffneten fenster gehen und einmal
nach frischer luft schnappen terror
einmal luft schnappen der sauerstoff
muss für die ganze klasse reichten klar
könnte mobile luftreiniger anschaffen
die nachweislich was alle viren aus der
luft filtern
aber würde man alle klassenzimmer in
deutschland mit guten geräten ausstatten
würde das maximal eine milliarde euro
kosten schätzen experten
zum vergleich alleine für unternehmen
sollen in diesem jahr 200 milliarden
euro an corona hilfen fließen was kommt
ihr denn jetzt so traurig warum geht er
auch zur schule und habe keine
unternehmen in anderen ländern arbeiten
die plagen längste neuer wald darf keine
hilfe dafür jeden tag neue hygiene tipps
vom schulamt hände waschen dann fünf
minuten lüften 20 minuten unterricht
dann wieder luft
dresden durch und wie zum henker bringt
man die dummen kinder dazu in der pause
abstand zu halten und hört man sich
insbesondere für die pause etwas
überlegt das können wir uns mal
anschauen
wir sehen hier kreise die auf dem boden
aufgezeichnet sind so ganz vorbildlich
läuft das hier gerade ab das ist so wie
ich es auch nicht draußen sind noch
nicht live übertragen das heißt man hält
sich an die regeln ja gerade
grundschulkinder haben diesen
idiotischen bewegungsdrang
vielleicht muss man jedoch an ketten
keine ahnung in nrw haben viele schulen
jetzt einen brief an die eltern
geschickt da steht drin kein witz die
schüler sollen wegen der lüfte rey
decken mitbringen muss sich halt zu
helfen wissen das wird ein langer langer
winter aber die gute nachricht ist wir
müssen die neandertaler gar nicht mehr
dran nehmen weil wir leben ja selber im
neandertal geschichte aus erster hand so
kinder jetzt holen allemal die speere
raus und wir jagen eichhörnchen für die
schulkantine
[Applaus]
deutschlands lehrer sagten einfach mal
danke für gar nichts ich wollte euch nur
um ein kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt